[Music]  what's your name Laura setting Croft  Laura  your father's gone you could pick up  where he left off I see so much of him  in you  brilliant hello sprout if you're  listening to this then I must be dead  I found something a tool called the  mother of death if Trinity succeeds our  world is in danger promise me you will  stop them I promise I think I know where  my dad went that's right in the middle  of the devil sea it will be an adventure  death isn't a hundred an adventure  [Music]  [Music]  you shouldn't have come here  but I'm glad that you did  what do you know about my father now I  see the lightness to recklessness close  the to once and for the fate of humanity  is now in your hands  [Music]  don't be too careful these days  the world has gone bloody mad I'll take  two  [Music]